[Music]
you're so far
away I wonder if you hear what I
say there time for you I can't see you
that's how I feel I love you are the sky
at night black and
white that's how I feel you're so
beautiful
beautiful that's how I feel about
you that's how I feel about
you
[Music]
honey in my
te your jam tastes the sweetest to
me this love for you I
can't that's how I feel you on the night
black and
white BL that's how I feel you're so
beautiful
beautiful that's how I feel about you
oh that's how I feel about
[Music]
you
you're so far
away I know that you'll be back any
day I am a you
are that's how I feel you are the sky at
night black and
white
that's how I feel you're so
beautiful
[Music]
beautiful that's how I feel about
you that's how I feel about
you that's how I feel
about
that's how I feel about
[Music]
you
how I feel about